for more information on tutoring
personalized video solutions or how to
support move university and the
production of more videos check out move
university comm thank you and enjoy okay
so next up the amino acids that are
degraded to alpha ketoglutarate and how
many amino acids are they are there that
have their carbon skeleton degraded
directly to alpha keto good right there
are five five of them they are one
arginine to prolene three glutamine four
go to mate and five histidine so let's
see what's going on with those okay so
we'll start off over here on the top
left with arginine first thing that will
happen is that will remove this group
here that will come off as urea in the
Arjun ace reaction and of course Arjun
age should be familiar because that is a
urea cycle enzyme so urea cycle enzyme
and of course the product of that
reaction after losing that one carbon is
ornithine and this ornithine is
converted into this or anything is
converted into glutamate gamma semi
aldehyde which basically gets rid of
this amino group here and the sidechain
attacks it on to the alpha ketoglutarate
to produce glutamate and we get this
aldehyde at this carbon right here go
from that carbon there to now the height
and this is catalyzed by ornithine Delta
amino transferase right because it's not
acting on not acting up here on the
alpha carbon so that gives us glutamate
gamma semi aldehyde we can also get the
semi aldehyde from breakdown products of
prolene so up here to the top right
we'll start with prolene which already
has five carbons so does not the gain or
lose I need to get to this point but it
does have that ring there from the
sidechain coming back and binding to the
alpha nitrogen
so the first thing that happens is that
prolene oxidase will cause the basically
put a double bond between or a cross
between these two portions here okay so
we'll get that double bond there and
that double bond is cleaved such that
this carbon ends up being this semi Alda
hide or that aldehyde carbon okay
and so both prolene and arginine end up
here with this glutamate canvas let me
aldehyde which can be turned into
glutamate by an enzyme called glutamate
semi aldehyde dehydrogenase of course
that requires a nd plus or nadp+ and so
we oxidize this carbon from going from
an aldehyde to a carboxylic acid group
or a carboxylate group and now we have
glutamate and you'll notice a lot of
arrows pointing at glutamate and that's
because basically all these things end
up as at glutamate and then once we have
glutamate the glutamate dehydrogenase
reaction can give us some nadh or NADPH
when removing or removing that that
amino group to give the alpha keto
Glitter rate that can go to the TCA
cycle okay so and of course how do we
get glue to meet glutamate from
glutamine always to do is hydrolyze off
this amide nitrogen to give the
carboxylate group and that happens via
the gluts a minase reaction which you've
seen before so we free up that ammonium
ion which of course would have to go
through the urea cycle so that accounts
for arginine prolene glutamate and
glutamine
now how about histidine histidine will
start down here so we got histidine here
first thing we're gonna do is remove
this amino group and that hydrogen as an
ammonium ion and we're gonna put a
double bond between these two carbons
right here and so that's going to be
done by histidine ammonia
Elias or hiss today's to give euro can
eight which looks like that and that
euro can 8 is going to be acted on by
Euro can eight hydratase and what
that'll do is that'll get rid of this
double bond here make that single bond
and also put a carbonyl at this carbon
up here so that's how we get that
carbonyl and we got the single bond here
now to give us this molecule for
emitters alone five propionic propionate
okay and that can be converted into an
for me to glutamate by this enzyme and
midazolam propio NACE and what you'll
notice is that this portion of the
molecule looks a lot like glutamates
really we just have this excess portion
here hanging on to that alpha amino
group and that is specifically a form
amino group and that form that's why
it's called n form amino glutamate and
so that that form amino group can get
tacked on to th F in a one carbon
transfer reaction into form and v form
amino THF by glutamate form amino
transferase so once you get that one
carbon group off then you have glutamate
which like we said before can undergo
the glutamate dehydrogenase reaction to
give a little rate which can go through
the TCA cycle and give us some energy
okay so I hope that video is helpful
thank you for watching if you found that
video helpful don't forget to like
comment subscribe and share with friends
thank you and happy studying